[Música]
hablamos de economía con jorge hurtado
jorge bienvenido muy buen día vamos a
hablar de china el gigante inmobiliario
evergrande y su deuda le pregunto qué ha
pasado actualice nos de este gran caso
en china bueno como recordará evergrande
tiene una deuda de más de trescientos
mil millones de dólares eso es más o
menos el producto interno bruto de un
país como chile y estaba por vender una
participación del 50 por ciento a un
rival más pequeño pero las negociaciones
se cayeron el negocio lo haría con hop
son de balonmán holding pero en una
presentación en la bolsa de valores se
brain dijo que tenía motivos para creer
que el joven no había cumplido con el
requisito previo para hacer una oferta
general por su unidad la venta iba a
representar 1500 millones de dólares
pero evergrande se negó a vender sólo
después de que altos funcionarios del
gobierno chino buscarán tranquilizar a
los compradores de vivienda hacia los
mercados afirmando que no se va a
permitir que los problemas en el sector
inmobiliario se convirtieran en una
crisis a gran escala
son you quien es funcionario de la
comisión reguladora de la banca y
seguros de china dijo en una sesión
informativa en beijing que ever gran es
un caso individual y calmó los nervios
de los mercados la deuda de esta empresa
representa el 2% del producto interno
bruto de china y las acciones de ever
ground se desplomaron hasta un 14% sólo
después de que la compañía dijera que
puso fin a las negociaciones la empresa
obtuvo una nueva extensión de más de
tres meses para pagar un bono de 260
millones de dólares emitidos por jumbo
for zion bueno ahora a jorge vamos a
hablar de otro tema que me llamó la
atención inflación en canadá así que
bueno el organismo público de
estadísticas de canadá presentó sus
indicadores de septiembre y dio a
conocer que la tasa de inflación anual
ahí creció tres décimas y se situó en el
4,4 por ciento en septiembre este es el
nivel de inflación más alto alcanzado en
ese país desde hace 18 años el organismo
señaló que excluyendo la subida de la
gasolina la inflación aumentó en el mes
pasado en un 3,5 por ciento el alza de
septiembre de raúl fue superior a lo que
había visto los economistas pero no es
lo único que aumentó los precios de los
principales componentes del indicador
aumentaron en septiembre liderado por el
transporte que experimentó una subida
del 9,1 por ciento los precios de la
vivienda y de la alimentación también
crecieron un 4,8 y 3,9 por ciento
respectivamente para los canadienses
moverse en vehículos era más caro el
costo de la adquisición de nuevos
vehículos aumentó en los pasados 12
meses un 72 por ciento y los economistas
raúl anticipan que la inflación se va a
mantener por encima de la meta del banco
central canadiense hasta el próximo año
estaba que me habla abajo yo estoy muy
enérgico hablamos a house la seguimos
hablando del inflación pero en europa
vale así en ese continente el fondo
monetario internacional descartó una
espiral inflacionaria como se ha venido
hablando los últimos días alfred kaymer
quien es director del departamento de
europa del fmi aseguró en una rueda de
prensa que el aumento de precios de la
energía es temporal y se debe a las
actuales alteraciones en las cadenas de
suministro global según el funcionario
los altos índices de inflación en europa
se disipará durante el 2 22 el aumento
en la factura energética raúl que tienen
repercusiones en los precios de los
consumidores tiene sus reyes en el
precio del gas que se ha multiplicado
hasta 5 veces desde el año pasado el
funcionario apuntó también que existe un
desequilibrio entre la oferta y la
demanda así como la transición hacia
energías renovables que no siempre están
disponibles con lo que se debe recurrir
al gas un reciente informe de el fm y
cito la inflación estimada para la zona
euro en el 2,2 por ciento para el cierre
de este año y un 1 8% para el próximo
jorge ahora le pregunto por los
indicadores iniciamos con hacia ahí las
acciones indias cerraron a la baja el
jueves por tercera sesión consecutiva ya
que las pérdidas de las acciones de
tecnología superaron las ganancias de
los bancos las acciones europeas cayeron
desde máximos de seis semanas con las
mineras liderando las caídas debido a la
preocupación sobre el sector
inmobiliario de china específicamente
verán que antes comentábamos para
finalizar que nos trae el jorge como
cifra del día en ese primer bloque
deportivo directo américa bueno tiene
que ver con la red social 'facebook' que
va a pagar una multa de entre 4,75
millones de dólares y 9 5 millones de
dólares de esto dirigido a las víctimas
por un caso con el departamento de
justicia de eeuu que denunció a facebook
de discriminar a trabajadores
estadounidenses y favorecer a
extranjeros con visas especiales para
puestos de alta remuneración bloque
económico jorge no deportivas que acaba
de ver a federico llegando el estudio
para dejarlo bloque deportivo ya casi
pero primero vamos con nuestro reportaje
del día jorge para
[Música]